في قاعدة عسكرية أوكرانية مؤقتة سرية،
يتم إنزال إحدى أحدث قطع الترسانة الأوكرانية في الماء، وهي
تزأر في المياه المفتوحة
تحت سيطرة هذا الطيار الذي
طلب منك عدم إظهار وجهه، إشارة النداء شارك،
هذا هو أحدث بحر أو أوكرانيا  طائرة بدون طيار
مصممة لمهاجمة روسيا في
البحر الأسود
ولم يتم عرضها للعامة
قبل أن يكون هذا النموذج مسلحًا بـ 300
كجم أو ما يقرب من 700 رطل من
المتفجرات ويمكنه إصابة هدف على بعد 800
كيلومتر 500 ميل ومن
السهل جدًا التحكم فيه  يخبرنا سمك القرش وقد
حدوا بشدة من تحركات البحرية الروسية،
ترسل أوكرانيا طائرات بدون طيار بحرية
للصيد وهي تحرث عبر الأمواج، إذا تم
رصدها، تفتح السفن الروسية النار بشكل محموم
أحيانًا، يكون الروس محظوظين
ويتمكنون من إخراجها وفي أحيان أخرى
تخترق الطائرات بدون طيار البرد.  من الرصاص
والوصول إلى أهدافها في أكتوبر الماضي،
نفذت طائرات بدون طيار تابعة للبحرية الأوكرانية
هجومًا مذهلاً على الميناء الرئيسي لأسطول
البحر الأسود الروسي وشبه جزيرة
القرم الروسية المحتلة، مستهدفًا السفينة الرئيسية
الأدميرال ماكاروف،
ويمكن لهذه الطائرة بدون طيار القيام
بالمراقبة والاستطلاع من بين
العمليات الأخرى.  تم
تصميمها وإنتاجها بالكامل في أوكرانيا
وفقًا لمطورها الذي
طلب أيضًا عدم الكشف عن هويته لأسباب أمنية.
ما مدى فعالية الدفاعات الروسية
ضد هذه الطائرات بدون طيار؟
المعدات الموجودة على سفنهم
مصممة لمهاجمة السفن الأخرى،
ولا يمكنهم ضرب مثل هذه الطائرات الصغيرة بدون طيار.
أسرع من أي شيء آخر في البحر الأسود،
أظهر الهجوم المذهل الذي وقع قبل فجر الأسبوع الماضي على جسر كيرتش الروسي الدمار
الذي يمكنهم إحداثه على الجسر، وهو
خط إمداد حيوي من روسيا إلى شبه جزيرة القرم،
وقد تعرض لضربة بطائرتين بدون طيار وترك أضرارًا جسيمة
ردًا على ذلك.  قالت روسيا إنها شنت
أيامًا من الضربات المكثفة على شاطئ البحر في
أوديسا زاعمة أن المدينة الساحلية الأوكرانية
تضم طائرات بدون طيار بحرية.
المعدات الروسية تعود إلى القرن العشرين
ومعداتنا تعود إلى القرن الحادي والعشرين، هناك
مائة عام بيننا